[Musique]
il ya des pressions plus plus sur les
salariés et d'études avec un des pelles
sur des questions sur qu'est ce que vous
faites est ce que vous avez fait ce qui
est ce que vous avez fait ça et des
points visio tous les jours qu'ils ont
un peu épuisé les salariés ce sont
surtout des activités j'allais dire
administratives ou commerciales qui
peuvent se faire à en télétravail c'est
surtout que des travail que le problème
s'est posé parce que les salariés qui
ont pu revenir totalement partiellement
sur site
enfin tout ce qui peut être industrielle
où on a besoin des gens sur site pour
faire la production de ce côté-là ça
c'est plutôt assez bien passé un
dialogue social avec les institutions
représentatives du personnel et quand il
n'y en a pas peut-être faire des groupes
de salariés en fonction des métiers et
faire du dialogue social entre le chef
d'entreprise et ses groupes pour trouver
et règles adaptées entreprises parce que
les règles ne peuvent pas kedem une tpe
pme aux grands groupes